pay special attention to this paper it
is not a paper by
google or deep mind or meta or anything
like this yet i believe it is a really
important paper it discusses typical
sampling which is a new decoding
strategy of how we sample from language
models we usually train language models
with a maximum likelihood objective that
put a lot of weight on very likely words
and when we use these models to produce
language we either explicitly or
implicitly reproduce that we make these
models sample very highly likely strings
which
are boring and not human-like it's not
what we do i don't say things that are
just highly likely because i actually
want to say something interesting and
that means that every now and then i
should utter something that's less
likely i should speak a word or a
sentence that you didn't expect because
that's what transmits information
typical sampling does exactly that and
does it in a principled fashion this
video right here is a description a
review of the paper and the next video
is going to be an interview with clara
meister the first author of the paper
both videos but especially the interview
are super duper interesting i would
definitely invite you to check them both
out and i would definitely invite you to
try out typical sampling it is in
hogging phase and whenever your
objective is to sample something that is
very you know high quality but also
diverse and interesting and not just
bland high likelihood text then that is
your method for you i believe that we do
need new sampling strategies and this
one is very promising check it out leave
a like and see ya hi let me quickly tell
you about fully connected which is
curated space for the applied ml
community it features articles project
reports news events and anything you
could want especially the projects page
acts as a little bit of a product hunt
for ml so feel free to add your own
project right here it's curated by
weights and biases but i know what
you're thinking yeah another company
blog whatever about their products but
this is not at all about weights and
biases it features some of their stuff
of course but it is generally a really
good resource to get good information on
what's currently happening in deep
learning they have great articles and
tutorials like there's one on solving
wordle with reinforcement learning which
is pretty cool there's one explaining
group normalization in pi torch and
there's one that explains you how to run
yolo v5 object detection on windows so
as you can see they have all kinds of
stuff and the list of already existing
articles is long if you still don't
believe me that it's not all weights and
biases in fact you can submit a post
there you can click the button write a
post it will be reviewed by them and
then published so one of the coolest ml
startups currently is going to push your
content how great is that now if you are
just a lurker like me then you know head
over there and subscribe because it's
user submitted but curated so you get
the best of both worlds besides articles
they also have events which usually
means their webinars about various
topics you can look at old webinars but
you can also subscribe to get updates on
new ones they also host their podcast
there gradient descent and the current
episode is actually with jensen huang
the ceo of nvidia so pretty big hitter
and lastly it includes the good old
weights and biases community forums
where you can get all kinds of help on
weights and biases product and beyond
weights and biases to all kinds of
things machine learning related so again
fully connected it just got a major
redesign please check it out go over
there subscribe for awesome articles and
news there's new stuff all the time
thank you so much to weights and biases
for sponsoring this video they've been a
great sponsor so please check them out
that's 1db.ai
fully connected now let's get into the
video see ya
hello there today we'll look at typical
decoding for natural language generation
by clara meister thiago pimentel john
wiher and ryan cotterell this paper
suggests a new way of decoding of
producing text from a large language
model or a small language model it
doesn't matter we don't discriminate
here
in any case usually currently you might
have heard of things like beam search
you might have heard of things like
nuclear sampling and top k sampling
these things are all right and
interestingly enough these stochastic
methods like nucleus and top k sampling
are better than the methods that try to
find the most likely things such as beam
search or greedy decoding
however
it's still not satisfactory large
language and small language models they
often produce text that is boring
just kind of bland when you actually use
them even though they have amazing
perplexities on text this paper tackles
this it proposes that when humans
generate text they don't just produce
the most likely text they will actually
trade off likelihood with information
content or or the transmission of
information to another human and that
trade-off can be captured in the
frameworks of information theory and we
can we can generate or we can suppose a
decoding scheme which they call typical
decoding typical sampling
which
exactly encapsulates that notion of
balancing interestingness or information
with likelihood and when they test it
that actually results in in better
results this could be really crucial
because it doesn't require any change to
how we train language models in fact we
can take off-the-shelf trained language
models and simply use this new decoding
strategy out of the box and it applies
across you know across domains now i
have long said that we need
that probably our decoding methods our
sampling methods may be inadequate
depending on what we do with those
language models for example
alpha code samples a whole bunch of
programs in order to solve a problem now
we again we don't like there is
value in diversity if you sample a whole
bunch and then after that use like a
filter to narrow it down
so i think depending on what you want to
do
maximum likelihood sampling is very
appropriate this paper for example
mentions natural or machine translation
because in machine translation you
really want kind of the the best
translation for a given input however in
other frameworks such as alpha code but
also such as storytelling this paper
mentions
summarization maybe as well you want to
we want to trade off some of this
maximum likelihood for some more
diversity or for some more
interestingness or for some more
information content and that's what this
paper does so we'll dive into it if you
like content like this as always leave a
like and don't be shy to let me know in
the comments what you think i'm not exa
i'm not entirely sold on what this paper
does i do agree we need better or we
need a different decoding strategies but
i do have my you know reservations about
this exact one
so
let's dive into the paper uh the paper
first complains about the exact thing i
complain about namely saying that
language models currently they have
extremely low perplexities on corpora
from many domains yet when used to
generate text their performance is far
from perfect and by that they mean um
yeah they they produce text that is
undesirable eg generic or degenerate
weight
yes
so either generic or degenerate or just
as i said boring bland um you know
and that comes from the fact that a lot
of these things they try to find the
maximal probability string so
they think you know i'm going to sample
from the probability distribution and i
want to sample what is the most likely
because
that's how we train these models right
so let's do a short excursion um if you
are unaware of how language models are
trained they're usually trained um you
have a sentence like the cat
is
in
something the house
and it goes on so what you do is you
input a part of the text and then you
let the model predict the next token and
then you input that part and you let the
model predict the next token now
in training this is all good and fine
but at inference time what you do is you
provide a prefix for example
the cat
and then you have to decode
here you have to decode a word what
what's next and then you feed that
whatever you decode it into the the
language model and you decode the next
word
and i think that's where part of the
problem comes from because during
training naturally what is here is given
by the data set so every new step that
you take if there is something unlikely
if there is a certain diversity to the
uh to the input that's captured by the
training data however in decoding you
sort of make your own data as you go
along here and
if you just always focus on finding very
likely next tokens you'll never get into
kind of a less likely environment which
could also be correct right so
that is that is one of the of the
problems however
obviously
in these language models the way they
work is
for example you input all of this into a
big model there is
some sort of a model which usually is a
transformer
nowadays and out comes a probability
distribution and the probability
distribution is over your vocabulary for
example there is the vocabulary this cat
dog
i've i don't know another word what's
another word house
something like this and it will give you
a distribution of probabilities over
these words and
you can now choose what to do either you
can take the maximum one which often it
runs into these problems of being boring
or even repetitive you can take you can
sample from this distribution which is
also not super appropriate because
and the paper
touches on this a little bit
because
sometimes the long what's called the
long tail here there are many many words
of course and they all have their sum
probability and
you don't want to get into these super
low probability words um because they
might just be artifacts of the model the
model doesn't represent these low
probabilities really well it's really
good at the sort of high probability
words because well it's essentially
trained
as a classifier and the classifier is
trained to give you the
correct label as the highest class and
it doesn't really care about the rest of
the words especially not the ones that
have really low probability
so what people do is they came up with
first of all beam search what beam surge
does is it considers multiple futures so
if it's here that cat
like uh
that cat
it considers multiple futures and it
looks a few steps ahead so it looks a
few steps ahead and it keeps a list of
things that are possible to complete so
for example in the beginning it goes all
these three routes and it keeps those in
mind along with the probabilities that
you go along that tree and then you know
you go ahead and maybe the buffer is
five large right so now we can still fit
it because there's one two three four
five paths currently but as soon as we
expand the sixth one this one here we
have to drop someone so we consider
all the paths and we consider only the
ones with the highest likelihood so far
this we can simply do by multiplying the
probabilities of consecutive decoding
steps we consider the most likely five
let's say paths so far
and we delete some of them let's say
that this one here is really low
probability and then once we add this
one here
and this one we have to drop another few
so let's say uh this one these two here
are really low probability and so on and
we only continue the paths that
have good probabilities or high enough
probabilities to be the highest possible
that's beam search and the reason why
people do it is because
there might so there might be a very
high likelihood sentence that you could
produce but the next word just happens
to be low in probability right maybe
here house
will lead to a sentence that down the
road is very likely has very good score
but just this word right now in in this
case is low probability because
the the immediate best word would be dog
for all the possible continuations or
for this particular prefix for all the
possible expected continuations
so beam search
beam search is even worse than greedy
decoding in the sense that it it really
finds the high probability stuff um it
doesn't and it looks ahead to be even
more accurate if you go to the opposite
end of the spectrum you can say okay can
we sample but can we fix the sampling
issues that arise from this tail and
that's why people do two things so
there's top k
um top case sampling and there is
nuclear sampling and they both both work
pretty much the same so top k sampling
what it does is you have again your
probability distribution um
and top k sampling simply
says well can we only consider the k
largest entries in that distribution and
then just sample from that so let's say
k equals three then we only consider the
three largest entries here and we just
forget about the rest and we only sample
from that we have to renormalize but
that's fine and then nucleus sampling is
very much the same except it says
well i'm going to afford myself a
probability uh a cumulative probability
of
of let's say 0.7
what does it mean it means that this
distribution right now has a cumulative
probability of one i am simply going to
take the largest ones like okay this one
and this one and this one until the
cumulative probability reaches my
maximum threshold maybe i'm going to
take this one as well you can see the
advantage here is that you don't always
pick the same amount
but you always pick sort of the
top entries that make up let's say in
this case 70 of the mass
and that is useful because you have to
consider multiple scenarios one scenario
is where the distribution is very peaky
like
there you only want to consider very few
entries so you only want to consider few
entries because everything else is just
really unlikely however if you
uh think of a distribution that is more
spread out
like this one
and then you want to consider more
entries because all of them are kind of
kind of likely and nucleus sampling
affords you that whereas top case
sampling would just disregard the shape
of the distribution and pick the top
ones right so these are the decoding
strategies but still you can see they
always go to the top or the most likely
things and this paper says well that's
kind of dumb and it shapes this as a
information theoretic problem
so we already said that
humans probably want to trade off the
likelihood of a string so like how
how likely it is to appear
meaning essentially how much it is
expected because if i just say things
that other humans expect right then i'm
not essentially not transmitting much
information at all
so
we can say that every string has a
a form or a content of information
actually i'm going to skip here
skip here to the
theory section directly and forgive me
i've pretty much explained all of what's
highlighted
already
so what we can say is that
a why why is the message that you want
to pass so let's say it's a sentence
the information content can be
quantified as its negative log
probability
essentially the less likely a
the less likely a given message is you
can see here that's negative negative
log probability the less likely message
is the more information it carries you
have to think of it like exactly as i
said if i say something that's very
likely the other person you know could
have expected it because it's so likely
um
it's like if you meet if you if you meet
the stereotypical
boring person or or if you see a movie
where it's like a really stereotype of a
boring person they will always say
exactly what you know what you'd expect
them to say however
uh if you say let's say you communicate
with someone and they all of a sudden
say something that you really didn't
expect now that's a lot of information
right there
in fact you can
by simple application of the chain rule
you can see you can also define a
information content for every single
word in the sentence and that is going
to be just the conditional log
probability at the log conditional
probability of that word given the
prefix and that's the prefix those are
the previous words in the sent so akin
to the information in a sentence a word
carries a lot of information if you
really didn't expect to see that word as
the next word in the current uh sentence
that you begun or that your
conversation partner has begun to say
so we carry this through and
the assumption here is that the goal of
an agent is to transmit information
efficiently while also minimizing the
risk of miscommunication
so that's the fundamental tradeoff that
humans do when they communicate at least
that's the hypothesis if you transmit a
lot of information um you're gonna have
to
utter some words that are very not
likely
because that transmits a lot of
information however if you overdo that
um and if you for example don't follow
the rules of grammar anymore and just
just send around low information
messages or high information likely
messages your
receiver will be confused because they
don't know what to make of it because
they really didn't expect to see
something like this and therefore
there is a chance of miscommunication
you can also
you can imagine that um
if you
if you want to transmit a message to
someone right if you want to explain
something to someone you always have to
adjust to what they already know like if
i want to explain uh the chain rule to
someone and i i expect them to already
know a little bit of math i'm going to
transmit a lot
i'm going to have to adjust my message
to that
and if i assume
too much of what they already know
and then i'll just end up saying
something like oh yeah if you derive f
of you know of g of x
um with respect to x then you have to
well you know you just derive g and then
you kind of multiply by the
by the derivation of f and it's all good
right it's all good um
so sorry for this butchering of the
chain rule but you can imagine that
someone who has little grasp of math in
the first place would be very very hard
because
i i
i only utter the words that carry so
much information that are so uh not
likely in their framework that um it
it there's a chance of
miscommunication i don't know if
actually that captures it the best maybe
there's a better example that's sort of
how i think of it
what they do define and now we get into
the decoding strategy is
the expected information the expected
information that a specific symbol in
the message will contain
so this formula right here you might
recognize as the conditional entropy of
a given
word in the sentence namely
and this i think the notation here is a
bit
out of place um i think it this should
be something like
uh the expectation of the information
content of just the t f word not
necessarily
uh y of t because y of t we we sum over
y of t right here so uh yeah but so we
ask ourselves if we have already
produced the sentence up to time step t
and we consider the distribution of
words conditioned on this sentence so we
ask our language model what's the
distribution of words that could come
next and we ask ourselves for each of
these one
what's the information content and since
we have the
the information content is the
negative log probability that's this and
here is the minus sign we ask ourselves
so what is the expected
information content of the next word you
know whatever the next word is what's
the expectation of its information
content if we were to just sample from
this probability distribution
and then this here is the formula right
we simply multiply whatever we're
interested in which is the information
content with the probability and we sum
that up across the set that we're
interested in that is it's just the
definition of the expected value and by
happenstance it is also the definition
of the entropy or the conditional
entropy so the expected information
content of any given position in a
sentence is the entropy
of is the conditional entropy of the
distribution at that point so what does
that mean that means if my distribution
is very peaked so if it's it's very
likely that one of these three words
here uh is uttered next is so if i find
a text somewhere right and the sentence
up to here was something and then
there's only like three words that could
potentially be there none else it's a
very peak to distribution that
essentially means the entropy is very
very low and therefore the information
content of that of whatever word comes
next
is probably going to be very low because
all these words are super likely
however if the distribution is very
shallow or very
broad
then the
the entropy is high and you can also see
since any of the words that could come
next first of all there are many more
that could be considered and
all of them have less of a likelihood
therefore the
um the negative log probability will be
higher so any of those words will have
more information content and especially
the expectation over those words it will
the information content will be higher
so that is just the definition of the
expected information content now here's
the hypothesis of this paper and they
base this on some you know psychologists
psychology theories or linguistic
theories but here's the hypothesis
any given word
should have an information content close
to the expected information content i.e
the conditional entropy given prior
context in other words we expect the
difference between the expected
information content and the true
information content to be small in human
like text
so the hypothesis here is that the way
humans balance this uh trade-off between
interestingness and and likelihood and
so uh in between information
transmission and not being misunderstood
is that they
implicitly calculate the expected
information content of the next word and
then they try to choose the next word uh
in accordance so that it is as close as
possible to that expected information
content so when i talk
i model sort of the the the
transmission channel to my receiver and
i figure out okay in the language right
now what would be the expected
information content of the next word and
then i try to match that as closely as
possible and that gives me a way of
determining this trade-off
again this is a hypothesis it's backed
up by a few theories from from
linguistics um this is also known in
information theory as typicality so a
typical message is one that
has the information content of
uh that is close to the expected
information content
um but we'll investigate
so
they say figure one shows for human
generated text the distribution of this
epsilon so this epsilon is the distance
between these two quantities the
expectation and the actual thing that's
uttered remember the expectation
considers all possible next words and
calculates the expected information
content of them and then the um this
thing right here uh the this thing is
just the information content of the next
word that is actually uttered or
actually written
so what what would we expect this
um or what do we see if we analyze human
generated text and these here these are
uh
these are obviously language models that
estimate the probabilities of these
words but these are evaluated on human
generated text so not on language model
generated text because remember this
paper is all about how do we do that in
order to not make the mistakes so let's
look at what humans do and you can see
the distribution is very peaked
now this isn't the distribution of words
this is the distribution of this epsilon
so
that essentially means
this distance this difference right here
is very very peaky and
it's peaky around a very small value you
can see here the scale
goes from
whatever
negative 10 to 20 or something
and the peak is at a value that's quite
close to zero now it's not exactly zero
but this is empirical
data so this paper says this is evidence
for the fact that humans
do as much as they can try to match the
information content to the expected
information content now it'd be
interesting to see what you would
actually let's say humans would just
sample from the distribution itself
right what what kind of distance between
the entropy and the information content
would you would you expect to see maybe
maybe a gaussian or a log gaussian um
i'm not entirely sure
also you know what what is peaky you
know what what does peaky even
like how do you characterize peak i can
see peaky but
you know it's proof by picture almost
and then we see a very interesting
imbalance namely there seems to be sort
of uh
mass going higher up always on the left
side of this
rather than on on the right side there
seems to be a bit of a longer tail on
the right side but a bit more
heavy mass on the on the left side now
what does that mean um
this is
well
i can't really make sense of it because
this is the this the epsilon is
characterized as an absolute value
whereas this right here is um
not an absolute value
and so i'm going to guess they left away
the absolute value therefore i don't
know
which
i don't know the distribution of the
deviation of information content from
the conditional entropy per token
okay
um
again i do not know
um
[Music]
what came first if they do h minus i or
if they do i minus h and that determines
how we interpret these plots so i'd
rather not
interpret them in the wrong way right
here
they further so that's what they say the
peaked nature of the distribution
reveals that humans indeed tend to form
language with per word information
content quite close to their expected
information content and the centering of
these distributions around the value
close to zero reveals that our
probabilistic language generators are
learning what this rate is
um
[Music]
well i'm i'm not sure i'm not sure
i agree with that statement because
being peaked
doesn't mean
doesn't mean
like you need both to be true at the
same time if you assume that the
language models are really good at what
they do
then you can claim that humans peak
around zero and therefore they match the
expected information content
if you assume that humans match the
expected information content
then you can conclude that language
models are really good at what they do
because the peak seems to be rather
around zero but you can't draw both
conclusions at the same time
from this plot because you need one to
justify the other in any case this is a
this is a minor point
what is interesting is that
here they go into information theory as
i said this notion of typicality which
is exactly what we're describing right
here they say it says typical messages
are the ones that we would expect from
its probability distribution their
average per symbol information content
is close to the entropy rate of their
source distribution
now the interesting observation right
here is that
the definition implies
that the highest probability message is
often not a member of this set its
average information content is too low
so
if we if we consider any distribution
and
we
consider
what's the expected information content
which is you know the way we defined it
and we only consider messages let's say
these are the messages we only consider
messages that are
close to that expected information
content but those are going to be
messages that are kind of somewhere in
the middle of the likelihood so they're
not super duper unlikely because the
expected information content is again
the the expectation over all of these
messages
which is going to be
not super duper high which makes these
rules out these unlikely messages these
are prone to misunderstanding but it
also rules out the very likely messages
because those are going to be
prone to being boring and not
transmitting any information at all
and that is something interesting that
is exactly the property we want in a new
decoding method leave away the really
low likelihood stuff and leave away the
really high likelihood stuff because
that's boring
um
yeah tip the typicality is a property
okay now they go into why we can't uh
why we have to go for local a local
notion of typicality whereas information
theory usually defines it as a property
of the um of the entire
sentence or of the entire message don't
necessarily want to go into that
the next chapter they try to justify
this with psycholinguistic concepts
there are two they consider there's the
uniform information density hypothesis
which
proposes that speakers construct their
utterances such that information is
distributed uniformly across them
and
the
the
speakers choose words such that their
information con their information rate
is closer to a target channel capacity
which is essentially what we're doing
right here
then there's the rational speech act and
the rational speech act sort of
um it casts a speaker's behavior as the
maximization of a utility function and
the utility function is a sentence's
usefulness to its listener
so the way constructs this again this is
sort of hypothesis it imagines this
literal speaker so this is a hypo
hypothetical speaker that just samples
from the probability distribution it
just looks at the probability
distribution and just samples from that
and it just utters the words as you know
as they come out and that means you know
with the typical problems like uh it's
going to other kind of low low
information stuff a lot of the times
then it says well
a smart the pragmatic speaker and that's
what the humans would be uh the
pragmatic speaker
produces sentences to maximize the
utility function as opposed to following
its li expected literal behavior
if you define the utility function to be
this thing right here then the
hypothesis kind of matches um the
hypothesis matches
the
this rational speech act however i find
this also to be a little bit shady
because if i have a different decoding
method in mind
i can apply the same argument i can
simply say well my
my utility function is now my new
decoding method
so
yeah i'm not super convinced by this
however uh it's interesting to see
that people think in this way that they
say well
there is going to be this literal
imaginary agent that just speaks
according to the distribution and then
there is the upgraded version of that
and probably the humans are a form of an
upgraded version this pragmatic speaker
that changes something that sort of uses
this distribution but changes something
about it
and that's exactly what we do
so
how do we do it
and we've already alluded to most of it
so what we do
is we introduce this typical sampling
much like nucleus sampling we define a
threshold in this case this is called
tau of probability mass that we're going
to allow in our
in our subset of words so again maybe we
have a distribution of a couple of words
and they have different likelihoods
under our language model output and we
assume our language model output models
these probabilities especially the
non-negligible ones
well
then what we're going to do is we're
going to calculate the expected
information content which is the
expected
negative log probability which is also
the conditional entropy so we're going
to estimate this property by simply
calculating it
we can do this this is simply again this
is p of x given y
times log p of x
given y
uh the log probability is usually
already
output by our model in the form of
logits we just need to normalize it and
if we apply some sort of a soft max
operation
we get the p of x given y
so
then we have the conditional entropy and
then we simply
choose the words that are most close
to this so maybe the expected uh the
entry let's say this is the let's say
these are the the log probabilities
right here let's say the expected the
expected one is
here
we simply choose in order the words that
are most close to that one so it would
be this one right here this is really
close
uh then this one is really close then
well it's a tough choice maybe this
one's really close and then maybe this
one's really close
and that we do that until again we reach
our target probability mass
again if the distribution is very peaked
so if the distribution is very peaked
that means um
the the uh
typical information content is going to
be lower which means the words that have
low information are going to be chosen
more which and these are also going to
be less words and
that gives us our original case back
where we're simply going to choose the
highest likelihood words into our bucket
to sample from
um
yeah and and that sort of regresses to
the old case if the distribution is very
peaky however if the distribution is
flatter or more broadly more broad
support then
we the expected information content is
going to be lower
which means that probably these highest
likelihood ones are not going to be in
it and we opt for more interesting ones
that are also likely but not as likely
so this kicks in mostly when there's a
lot of
possibilities which you can see in let's
say machine translation there is not in
machine translation it's often very
clear or there's only a few
possibilities on how to translate
something however in storytelling
there's lots of possibilities how things
could continue and there our
distribution are much more shallow and
this method would exploit that by saying
well i'm just not going to consider the
most likely things right here
the computational complexity is the same
as nucleus or top k sampling we also
have to determine
the set we're going to consider
by
somehow calculating across it we have to
aggregate it we have to renormalize it
and we have to sample from it except
here well i guess we always have to sort
right
yeah
here we also have to to calculate this
conditional entropy part it's the same
in complexity but it does add a constant
uh overhead or like a multiplicative a
constant factor overhead uh to the whole
thing
so
the last thing i want to go in here is
hype the choice of hyper parameters in
this one
they say we found k equals 30 and n
equals 0.9 to perform best so these
parameters perform best for top k
nucleus sampling respectively
so this is for their experiments
so one is for top clay sampling and one
is for nuclear sampling
for typical sampling we found that tau
equals 0.2 and tau equals 0.95
to provide the best results for story
generation and abstractive summarization
respectively so while they allow for a
single parameter
for each of the baselines they go with a
separate parameter for
different tasks for their method which
is a bit shady now there's two
possibilities first possibility is they
sort of stifle the baseline by only sort
of giving it
not exploring well enough
the the possibilities or what i think
happened most likely is that the same
parameter performs pretty well for all
the different tasks which is a good
property in itself right here here we
consider 20 of the probability mass and
here we consider 95 of the probability
mass now that's a huge difference in how
our set looks and that by itself
makes it in my opinion a bit of a weaker
choice for using this as a decoding
method because for every you know thing
that i want to achieve i need to
essentially tune this parameter whereas
with top k sampling i could just leave
it b so it'd be interesting to see if in
the future there might be because i'm
i'm i'm a fan of this um technique in
principle so maybe in the future we'll
we can find more of an adaptive way much
like nucleus sampling is an adaptive way
of top k sampling maybe we can come up
with an adaptive way of
of determining the
the number here or the parameter of how
many how many things to consider
um
so they i don't want to go too much into
the evaluation
uh there is there is a difference
sometimes it's stark sometimes it's not
as stark it is different in different
regimes you can see that depending on
the regime that you are at um
it's
it's sometimes the different methods are
really different uh sometimes they're
quite close sometimes they switch places
uh
yeah that's
i don't want to go too much into the
results because we can maybe discuss
them
in an interview
but
qualitatively say for for example for
the summarization task we see that
typical sampling provides a
comprehensive and coherent summary of
the article under consideration in
comparison nucleus sampling leads to
hallucinated facts for example getting
drugs from under okay i don't haven't
read the article but
nuclear sampling hallucinate facts which
is one property if you
sample only from high likelihood things
right you're just going to continue with
things that are very likely in the
language itself um rather than
transmitting the necessary information
while top case sampling misses some of
the important information in the article
eg the charges of burglary and arson and
that might be because top k sampling
simply has this fixed bucket of words to
consider and
as soon as one word is not in that
bucket it simply is forbidden from
uttering it even if the distribution is
shallow and that word is kind of likely
so i want to stop here
and just give a few thoughts
on on this
in my opinion i already said it is quite
needed that we have different decoding
strategies to achieve different tasks
this one right here it seems really
interesting it is a way to trade off
sort of not considering the most likely
things but also not considering the
least likely things however i'm not sure
if the notion of the matching the
expected uh information content is
appropriate i i can't tell it's a good
hypothesis
i don't know if this quantity here the
absolute distance is a good quantity
like why would it be the absolute
distance and the other issue i have
right here but this might be my
ignorance of information theory is
um
so if i change let's if i assume the
humans talk like this they choose their
words according to the expected
information content right and i use this
particular construction right here
that
is going
everything that comes out of this
whatever comes out of this will have a
different expected information
content than the original language right
if if i wanted to actually match like if
i wanted to keep the expectation i
probably couldn't do this just in
absolute difference that's probably
going to change the expected information
content let alone the the distribution
of it itself but just the expectation is
going to change now if you're telling me
that humans
do it like this and that our language
models are trained on text that is
written and uttered by humans
um
like wouldn't that text already have
that property and therefore sampling
from it would be the original
distribution
or in other words if i
produce text like this
like shouldn't i get the same shouldn't
i get the same distribution out that my
language model predicts because my
language model is trained on human text
and your claim is that humans sample
text like this so why would that be any
different from sampling from the
language model itself and
especially
shouldn't it be that the expected
information const content remains
constant if i apply this sampling
technique um i just out of out of
principle because
by definition if it doesn't then it
doesn't it is not
it doesn't match human generated text
because yeah because that's already the
input that's the training data
all right but maybe i'm i'm sort of
ignorant of information theory right
here my yeah my other concerns are with
the hyperparameter choice um
and
yeah i'd i'd be interested uh to dive a
little bit more into this like what
would we expect to see with the with the
different
sampling methods or with different
hypotheses this is also really
interesting but i'm going to leave it at
that
all i can say is that we should probably
try this out
and maybe you know for certain tasks
where diversity and actually
transmitting information is more
important than being
you know uttering the most likely thing
this might really be a cool application
and maybe we'll figure out an automatic
way to adjust the hyper parameters
let me know what you think maybe you've
already tried it out you can give a
little bit of a
of a report on how that went and i'll
see you next time bye
you